Oh
hi, ich bin Kate Adamson, willkommen zurück zu
Denkerinnen in der Antike im
Mittelalter, präsentiert vom King's
College London und der LMU München. Heute
sprechen wir
im vierten Teil der Serie über Denkerinnen im alten Indien
und offensichtlich
bewegten sich hier Kulturen, die wir
uns bisher mit dem antiken Griechenland angesehen haben,
und sie neigen auch dazu, die EU zu verlassen, also haben wir uns angesehen,
was im späteren Römischen
Reich in dieser und der nächsten Vorlesung passiert ist,
zu der wir nicht übergehen werden
-europäische Kulturen, also werden wir dieses Mal, wie ich
schon sagte, Indien betrachten und das nächste
Mal den Islam und die
Rolle von Intellektuellen in der
islamischen Welt. Viele Menschen wissen nicht
viel über indische Philosophie
Es gibt sogar eine Art
Kontroverse darüber, ob die indische
Philosophie Teil der Geschichte der
Philosophie ist.
Ich bin sehr stark der Ansicht, dass dies der Fall ist,
und ich denke tatsächlich, dass, wenn Sie
sich in einer indischen philosophischen
Literatur aus der Antike umsehen, dies vielleicht schon der Fall ist  Genauso wie
die Veden die alten Schriften
die medizinische Tradition in Indien atmen,
aber sicherlich mit den Upanishaden
und den vielen Denkschulen
, die aus dieser vedischen Tradition hervorgegangen sind,
dann besteht kein Zweifel daran,
dass dies philosophisches Material ist, und
auf der anderen Seite  Also auf der nicht
atemmedizinischen Seite, wenn Sie an die
Buddhisten und Jainas denken, die in einer Sekunde erklären,
dass es auch sehr philosophisches Material gibt,
weniger klar ist,
welche Rolle Frauen in der indischen philosophischen Tradition gespielt haben könnten,
wenn überhaupt, wenn
wir darüber nachdenken einige  der großen Namen
der indischen Philosophie wie Buddha
selbst oder ein Mojave, der Begründer des
Jainismus, oder einige der Figuren,
die die Upanischaden darstellten, waren dort große
Lehrer oder später, sagen wir, ein
großer buddhistischer Philosoph wie dieser Gott
Thunfisch oder eine der anderen Figuren  über wen
man lesen kann, wenn man indische
philosophische Texte durchsieht, keine von ihnen sind
Frauen, und in dieser Hinsicht ist es ein
bisschen so  Die antike griechische Philosophie, also sind
alle berühmten Namen männlich und auch ein
bisschen wie der Verlust der alten Trauer
im kulturellen Kontext, ist nicht wirklich
einer, von dem man erwarten würde, dass er weibliche Philosophen hervorbringt. Es
gibt eine sehr
starke Annahme in der alten indischen
Kultur, dass Frauen sie besetzen werden
Rolle im Haushalt, wie wir es in der
europäischen Antike gesehen haben, und es gibt eine Menge
Nervosität darüber, was passieren wird, wenn
Frauen aufhören, diese Rolle zu erfüllen, was
nicht heißen soll, dass Frauen
tatsächlich als erniedrigt angesehen werden, wie wir
sehen werden  Texte, die sich wirklich
dafür aussprechen, Frauen zu ehren und
ihnen sogar Ehrfurcht entgegenzubringen, aber das ist
die Art von Haltung gegenüber Frauen, bei der
sie auf ein Podest gestellt, aber nicht wirklich
eingeladen werden, an typisch männlichen Aktivitäten teilzunehmen,
vielleicht der typischsten männlichen
Aktivität  wäre ein typisches Beispiel und
dies ist ein Ritual, wie Sie vielleicht wissen, in
der vedischen Tradition und der
empfehlenswerten Tradition, die ihr vorausgeht,
heißt es b  Weil die
Brahmanen die Leute sind, die eine Art
Priester sind, sind sie tatsächlich an
der Durchführung des Rituals beteiligt und haben das
Wissen darüber, wie man es macht. Sie
legen großen Wert auf die Bedeutung des
Rituals, also opfern Sie den Göttern oft,
indem Sie so etwas verbrennen  eine Pflanze aus
der Pflanze namens Soma im Feuer und vedische
Texte sprechen viel darüber, wie dies zu tun ist.
Die Upanishaden beziehen sich häufig
auf das Ritual und wie es durchgeführt werden sollte
, was Sie durch
die Durchführung der Rituale erreichen können, zu welcher Zeit Sie
es tun sollten  und so weiter
und die Annahme ist, dass
der Opferer, der oft ein
reicher Mann sein wird, die Annahme ist, dass er
tatsächlich ein Mann und keine reiche Frau sein wird und
mittlerweile eine Art Analogon zu einem Priester ist,
der ihnen half, den
rituellen Willen auszuführen  auch ein Mann sein, also
beschwört das irgendwie das Bild eines
rein männlichen Titanen aus Eisen
in altindischen religiösen Ritualen herauf
, was jedoch nicht ganz stimmt, denn wie
sich herausstellt, gibt es auch Texte wh  Ich
sage, dass der männliche
Haushälter seine Frau dort haben muss und dass das Ritual
möglicherweise nicht effektiv ist, wenn seine Frau nicht
da ist, und so können Sie von diesem Standpunkt
aus sehen, dass
die Rolle der Frau in der Familie sehr betont wird  Ritual,
obwohl sie
weder auf der
Seite des Wissens, also auf der Seite des
Priesters, noch auf der Seite des Praktizierenden die Art des führenden Agenten im Ritual sind, so
dass der Hauptopferer als
der Mann angesehen wird, nicht als die Frau
Die Rolle der Frau ist sehr wichtig, dass
sie die Frau des Mannes ist. Sie kann
auch wichtig sein, weil eines der Standard-
Ritualziele in diesen vedischen Traditionen
ist, dass das Opfer sehr aufopfernd ist
, um einen Sohn zu haben oder Kinder zu haben
im Allgemeinen, aber natürlich  Die Hoffnung ist,
einen Sohn zu haben, und daher ist die Frau hier relevant
,
weil sie tatsächlich
diejenige sein wird, die teilweise schwanger wird. Aus diesem
Grund gibt es
in den Upanishaden vermutlich häufig Anspielungen auf
Frauen, aber oft mit  Bezug auf die
Fortpflanzung, so haben Sie
zum Beispiel symbolische Diskussionen über die weiblichen Genitalien,
und es ist interessant zu sehen, dass
Sie auch symbolische Beschreibungen des
männlichen Körpers haben, aber oft werden sich die Diskussionen
über den Körper des Mannes auf seinen
ganzen Körper beziehen, während sich die Diskussion der
Frau auf ihn konzentriert  an ihren Fortpflanzungsorganen
, das hat Ihnen also ein bisschen
etwas darüber gezeigt, wie besonders Art von
Oberschichtelite wir über Frauen gedacht haben,
besonders in einem religiösen
Kontext, das ist die brahmanische Seite
der Geschichte, also die Geschichte, die aus
diesen alten vedischen Traditionen stammt, aber  Wie
Sie vielleicht von Anfang an wissen, gibt es
in der indischen Kultur eine Alternative zu den
okkulten Traditionen
der Rockmänner, und das nennen wir die Shona-
Traditionen, was manchmal
als Entsager übersetzt wird, und es gibt
mehrere Schulen,
die bei weitem die berühmtesten unter diese Überschrift fallen  Die
Buddhisten sind offensichtlich vom
Buddha gegründet, der lebte, wann immer er es ansah, ist
sehr umstritten  Aber es gibt nicht nur
Buddhismus, sondern auch Jainismus, der,
wie gesagt, von Mahavira
und seinesgleichen in dem Sinne gegründet wurde, dass
die wirklich überzeugte Anhängerschaft sowohl des
Buddhismus als auch des Jainismus auf dieses
rituelle Leben und auch auf das Leben des
Haushalts verzichtet, wie Sie es vielleicht beschwören
Denken Sie an diese Vorstellung von buddhistischen und jainistischen
Mönchen, die sich in die Wildnis zurückziehen, auch
wenn sie vielleicht keine normale Kleidung tragen
, in Gemeinschaften leben und betteln, um
zu überleben, und ganz allgemein
aus der Gesellschaft aussteigen, die hier fast
als Vergleich mit den Zynikern
in der Antike erscheinen könnten  Griechenland Gesellschaft, über die wir
kurz gesprochen haben, als wir uns mit der
Philosophie in der Spätantike befassten, und daher ist es
die gleiche Idee, zumindest insofern, als
wir eine Art Ablehnung der Werte
der großbürgerlichen Gesellschaft und sogar der
Ablehnung des gesamten Haushaltslebens
haben  Das wirft im Allgemeinen viele
Fragen auf, aber natürlich ist für uns die
wichtigste Frage bei Rennen, ob das
Leben des berühmten Sirs av ist  verfügbar
für Frauen, und auch hier ist das
Bild eher gemischt, so dass es im
Buddhismus eine Tradition gibt, dass der Buddha selbst
es widerstrebte, Frauen zu erlauben,
das Leben eines buddhistischen Mönchs anzunehmen, oder wir könnten
jetzt sagen, Buddhismus keiner, wie Sie vielleicht irgendwann wissen werden
Sie waren buddhistische Nonnen, aber
die Idee ist, dass er deswegen ziemlich nervös war
und angeblich
die Anwesenheit von Frauen in der klösterlichen
Gemeinschaft mit Mehltau verglich, der die Ernte
auf den Feldern befallen hat. Er sagte angeblich auch,
dass seine Gemeinschaft tausend Jahre überleben würde,
aber nur  500 Jahre, wenn
Frauen und
seine Anhänger
ihn dazu überredeten, sowohl buddhistische Nonnen als
auch buddhistische Mönche zuzulassen, und dies war der Fall,
also hat er sowohl Frauen als auch Männer,
die das Leben ihres Ansagers
im Buddhismus leben, was ist mit dem
Jakobus in diesem Fall?  der James, die
übrigens wahrscheinlich am bekanntesten für ihre
extreme Gewaltlosigkeit sind, also ist
dies die Tradition, die Sie vielleicht gesehen haben,
wo sie zum Beispiel gehen  zusammen mit einer
Gesichtsmaske, um das Verschlucken von Insekten zu vermeiden,
und sie fegen den Boden vor
sich, um nicht darauf zu treten. Sie
reisen nicht in der Regenzeit, weil
sie eher auf Insekten
oder andere kleine Kreaturen treten, weil sie nie
Feuer benutzen  es würde die Kreaturen töten
und natürlich sind sie strenge Vegetarier,
also sind sie auch eine Art Ankündigungsbewegung
, die bereits als eine
Art ästhetische Bewegung suggeriert, genau wie der
Buddhismus, und hier gibt es eine
Meinungsverschiedenheit innerhalb des Jainismus, so dass sich der
Jainismus schließlich in zwei Arten aufspaltet
Flügel oder man könnte sagen Sekten die so
genannten White Clad und Skyclad Chains Der
Grund, warum die Sky Clad Chains
Skyclad genannt werden, ist, dass sie überhaupt nichts tragen,
also sind sie immer wieder nackt.
Natürlich ist das eine Form der Askese,
also vielleicht  Nudisten würden dem nicht zustimmen,
aber anscheinend soll das Leben ohne
Abschlüsse eine Art Mühsal
und schwierig sein, besonders wenn man
daran denkt, es im Winter richtig zu machen,
und der Skyclad James tat es  Ich glaube nicht, dass
Frauen beitreten könnten, also waren sie eine
rein männliche Gruppe, und das Argument
dafür war im Grunde gut, man kann nicht
nackt herumlaufen, zum Beispiel würde
sie einem sexuellen Angriff aussetzen, während
die anderen Ketten tot waren, außer Frauen, das
war sehr wichtig, weil  Die James
glaubten, dass es ein Weg war,
sich einer dieser klösterlichen Gemeinschaften anzuschließen, um ein berühmter Herr zu werden,
genauso wie die Buddhisten
glaubten, dass dies ein Weg wäre, um
von dieser
Welt in die Welt des Leidens befreit zu werden, und das
ist in gewisser Weise tatsächlich eine Art
Ziel  vereint all diese Traditionen,
also werfen Sie es und wieder die Spitzentradition
, die aus der vedischen Kultur
in der allgemeinen indischen Philosophie stammt, tendiert
dazu, diese Art von soteriologischer oder
eschatologischer Dimension zu haben, wo wir
vielleicht über philosophische Probleme sprechen und sie könnten sehr technische
sein wie die  Die Natur des Selbst Wenn
es ein Selbst gibt Die Natur der Zeit Die
Natur des Weltraums Kosmologie Wir werden
die Idee sehen  Das ist später so, aber der
Punkt dabei wäre immer, eine
Art von Wissen zu erlangen, das Ihnen hilft,
eine Art Befreiung zu erreichen, entweder
von der Befreiung von der Welt
des Leidens, wie ich gerade sagte, mit
Buddhismus und Jainismus, das ist ein sehr starker
Buddhismus  die Sie wahrscheinlich kennen, oder
vielleicht ist die Befreiung von irgendeiner Art von
Anhaftung an materielle Dinge
wieder ein Thema des Buddhismus, aber es könnte
auch in der trockenchemischen Tradition der Fall sein, dass
die Befreiung durch
philosophische Einsicht erfolgt, denn sobald Sie
Ihren wahren Platz im
Universum kennengelernt haben  du wirst effektiv eins mit Gott
oder vielleicht wirst du eins mit einem
Bewusstsein, das hinter allen
Dingen steht, und du bist befreit von diesem
rein körperlich-physischen
Alltag, den du bisher geführt hast,
so dass diese Idee der Befreiung so
eine Art ist  vereint in den meisten indischen
Philosophien, wenn nicht sogar
in der Philosophie, ist das Sanskrit-
Wort natürlich Moksha und so wirklich, worüber wir
hier in Th sprechen  Der Sinn ist,
ob Frauen dazu in der Lage sind, dies zu
erreichen, also dürfen
sie an allen Aktivitäten teilnehmen
, die zur Befreiung oder zu
noch bescheideneren Zielen führen sollen, wie die Art von
Zielen, die in vedischen Ritualen verfolgt wurden,
was hätte sein können  mehr aus Mangel an einem
besseren Wort materialistisch wie Reichtum oder
eine Familie haben oder so lange okay, das ist
also eine Art allgemeines Bild des
Kontexts, über den wir hier sprechen
werden. Ich werde eigentlich hauptsächlich
über Text sprechen  Vedische
Seite der Geschichte, einfach weil wir uns
hier auf tatsächliche Denkerinnen konzentrieren wollen, und
zum größten Teil werden die Denkerinnen, die
wir in der alten philosophischen
Literatur finden können, im weitesten
Sinne in medizinischen Texten und nicht in
buddhistischen Texten vorkommen  die
Arbeit, die buddhistischen Nonnen zugeschrieben wird
, die in der Antike auftaucht, was
ziemlich interessant ist, aber ich werde nicht
wirklich darüber sprechen, ich werde mich
auf Text konzentrieren  aus der Tradition der Atemmedizin
Okay,
um zuerst etwas
mehr über die Einstellung gegenüber Frauen in der
medizinischen Literatur zu sagen, wir haben bereits gesehen,
dass ihnen eine
wichtige Rolle in Ritualen zugeschrieben wurde und dass
sie oft mit großer
Hingabe behandelt wurden  und auf der anderen Seite haben
wir bereits gesehen, dass
sie Männern als sehr untergeordnet angesehen werden,
da sie nur eine Art
funktionale Rolle spielen, also sind sie da, um
den Haushalt zu führen, sie sind da, um dem Mann zu helfen
, Kinder zu bekommen  In dieser Hinsicht ist
es sehr vertraut aus dem, was wir
aus dem antiken Griechenland gesehen haben, und diese Art von
Dualität kommt in einem sehr wichtigen Text zum Ausdruck, einer
Art rechtlichem oder ethischem Text aus
der frühen Akkulturation der schwarzen Männer,
den Gesetzen von Manu und denen, die ich
zitieren möchte  daraus, und ich werde
Ihnen ein berühmtes Zitat davon geben, das
oft als eine Art
Frauenfeindlichkeit im alten Indien zitiert wird, also hier ist der
Test, dass ein Mädchen, eine junge Frau oder sogar eine alte
Frau nichts tun sollte
unabhängig selbst in ihrem eigenen Haus in der
Kindheit sollte eine Frau unter
der Kontrolle ihres Vaters und die Jugend unter der ihres
Mannes sein und wenn ihr Mann tot ist
unter ihren Söhnen sollte sie niemals
unabhängig sein, obwohl ihr Mann
ungehobelt und vergnügungsfreudig ist, obwohl
er keine guten Seiten hat  Überhaupt sollte die tugendhafte
Ehefrau ihren Herrn immer als Gott anbeten,
also nicht gerade das feministische
Gefühl. Wir finden positivere Ideen
in den Gesetzen des Bergbaus über Frauen, das
heißt, es gibt zum Beispiel eine Aussage in
den Gesetzen eines Bergmanns, dass die Götter wohnen
Überall dort, wo Frauen verehrt werden,
bekommt man wieder die Vorstellung, dass Frauen
fantastisch sind, solange sie ihren
Platz kennen, solange sie
angemessen untergeordnet und fügsam
sind und nur die Rolle spielen, die sie
im Haushalt spielen sollen  dann
lieben wir sie, aber sie sollten nicht, sie
sollten sich auf keinen Fall aufführen
und so tun, als wären sie auf der gleichen
Ebene wie Männer, das ist natürlich genau
das, was bei Frauen passieren würde
durften das Leben von Entsagern führen, und
wir werden diese Bedrohung
später sehen, wenn wir uns eine
Passage aus dem Mahabharata ansehen, aber bevor
wir darauf eingehen, möchte ich einen
Text aus den Upanishaden betrachten, die
wirklich sind  Einige der interessantesten
Spuren von Frauen aus der alten Kultur im
Allgemeinen, ob in Indien oder
anderswo, weil wir Frauen haben,
die im Zusammenhang mit tatsächlichen
philosophischen Debatten dargestellt werden, nicht
nur mit Männern, sondern mit großen Weisen, sozusagen
Helden der Philosophie und  Sie bestraften
Chancen und insbesondere
sagen sie, dass sein Name Nadia ist, er wird so dargestellt, als würde er
sich
mit zwei Frauen in philosophische Gespräche verwickeln, eine von ihnen ist seine Frau, eine
andere scheint eine Art weibliche
Weise zu sein, die vor Gericht mit ihm streitet,
bevor wir in den Text kommen  Ich möchte
eine Warnung aussprechen, die ein
bisschen der Warnung entspricht, die ich normalerweise mache, wenn wir
uns die antike griechische Literatur
ansehen, insbesondere die wirklich klassische griechische
Literatur wie in der  Zeit von Platon und
Aristoteles, nämlich, dass wir hier sehr
vorsichtig sein sollten, anzunehmen, dass wir
eine tatsächliche historische
Darstellung von echten Frauen sehen, die
echte Gespräche mit einem echten
Philosophen namens Josh Nikita führten. Tatsächlich ist
die Situation hier, die wir sehen werden
ist wahrscheinlich sehr ähnlich zu dem, was wir bei
Plato gesehen haben, wo wir Frauen haben,
die real sein können oder nicht, also denken wir wieder über die
Gottheit ma nach und die Frage, ob
sie real ist, und sie werden im
Dialog mit einem männlichen Philosophen dargestellt,
um sie zu führen  Irgendwann wird die Frage
für uns also vielleicht nicht so sehr sein,
was wir hier über historische Denkerinnen lernen können,
sondern warum haben wir diese
historischen, diese angeblich historischen
Figuren in die Upanishaden eingefügt,
welchen Punkt versucht der Autor zu machen,
indem er a hat  weibliche Gesprächspartnerin in diesem
Stadium und hier wiederhole ich oder etwas
, das eine Gelehrte namens Stephanie
Jamison geschrieben hat, also sagt sie über dieses
Phänomen, dass wir uns der Tatsache stellen müssen, dass wir
sind  Wir werden die Stimme einer authentischen Frau nicht hören
oder zumindest nicht, ohne
von denen manipuliert zu werden, die sie
aus ihren eigenen Gründen in die Tradition eingefügt haben,
und ich denke, was sie damit sagt, ist
, selbst wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass eine der
Frauen dies tun muss  diskutieren, war eine
reale Person, wir sollten bedenken, dass
die Upanishaden sicherlich
von Männern geschrieben und dann weitergegeben wurden, also ist das, was
wir hier haben, bestenfalls eine Art
Fiktion, wir sind uns nicht sicher, wie
viel eine echte
Denkerin wirklich repräsentiert  nur in den
Dienst eines Autorenziels und
Upanishaden gedrängt zu werden, aber das ist besser als
nichts, also lass uns darüber reden,
also lass uns einen Blick auf die Bestrafungen werfen, und
bevor wir über die zwei Dialoge sprechen
, die ich im Sinn habe, möchte ich nur
etwas Allgemeines sagen  über die Pinienschüsse
als philosophische Tests, also ist ein offensichtlicher
Vergleich, den Sie mit Ihren Teichschüssen machen können,
etwas, das ich gerade
mehrmals erwähnt habe, Platons
Dialoge, nicht wegen der Upanish  Anzeigen sind
immer in Dialogform, sie sind es nicht und
nicht, weil sie alle von einer
einzigen Person geschrieben wurden, sie waren es sicherlich nicht
, sie wurden im Laufe
der Jahrhunderte von vielen verschiedenen Leuten geschrieben,
was ich meine, aber einige
manchmal  Angewandte Aufnahmen enthalten
Textabschnitte in
Dialogform, und das wird sich tatsächlich
auf die Passagen beziehen, die wir
uns jetzt ansehen werden, also ist das eine Sache, und
die andere Sache ist, dass wir im Allgemeinen
dasselbe haben, was wir finden  Plato ist
insofern diese hochgradig literarische Art
von klassizistischem Kontext, in dem
philosophische Ideen erforscht werden. Natürlich sind
die Ideen anders, also muss man
viel über kosmologische Ideen nachdenken,
etwas, das hier häufig vorkommt,
etwas, das ich bereits erwähnt habe, Vergleich
zwischen dem menschlichen Körper oder  Der Körper eines
Opfertiers und der gesamte Kosmos
, das ist eine ziemlich verbreitete Vorstellung, und die
Upanishaden bringen alle möglichen anderen
Diskussionen über verschiedene religiöse
Praktiken wie die  Verwendung von Mantras wie
alles, was zum Beispiel auf die
Apana-Aufnahmen zurückgeht und so weiter und so weiter.
Eine Sache, die ich etwas detaillierter erwähnen möchte,
ist eine philosophische Idee,
die für die
Dialoge, über die wir sprechen werden, relevant sein wird  darüber, und
es ist einfach an sich interessant, und
das ist der Begriff des heißen Schlauen, der
manchmal als das Selbst übersetzt wird, also, was
ist das, Mutter, na ja, es ist das Selbst, was bedeutet das, na ja
, es ist vielleicht das Zentrum der
Handlungsfähigkeit oder des Bewusstseins, das
vielleicht hinter den Dingen steht, die wir haben  tun, aber
besonders unsere Kognitionen, unsere
Wahrnehmungen, unsere Gedanken, unsere Erinnerungen,
und dies ist eine wirklich entscheidende Idee der
Upanishaden, die, wenn sie auf die Spitze getrieben
wird, schließlich Dinge wie
Vedanta hervorbringen wird, und insbesondere Hawaii
leitet sie an eine spätere Denkschule weiter, die besagt
, dass die ganze Welt ist  nur eine
Art Manifestation eines reinen Bewusstseins,
das manchmal auch Bronfman genannt wird,
also könnte man auf die Idee kommen, dass es
überhaupt nichts anderes als Gottes
Betrug gibt  Bewusstsein, das auch unser
Bewusstsein ist, und dann gibt es die
Dinge, derer sich das Bewusstsein bewusst ist, aber
das sind in gewisser Weise nur Repräsentationen
, die vor dem einzelnen
Bewusstsein stehen, und letztendlich wäre der Sinn
der Philosophie, Sie dazu zu bringen,
Ihre Identität mit diesem reinen Subjekt zu sehen oder
Dieses reine Bewusstsein, das ein
Dilettant war, oh, ich sage offensichtlich nicht
, dass das eine Idee ist, die wir
in alle Upanishaden oder vielleicht einen
von euch bestraften Verrückten zurücklesen sollten, aber sicherlich wurden die
On-Codes als Hauptquelle verwendet
, die Ideen wie was inspirierte  Wir haben das getan,
was ich gerade in Advait Vedanta beschrieben habe,
und die Idee, wie man ein
Selbst hinter einer Erfahrung abzubauen hat
, die sehr von der Metaphysik davon bestraft ist
, und ob es eine Art Monismus impliziert,
wie ich gerade sagte, das ist ein
anderes Thema als wir  Ich habe in diesen Texten eine Art
konsequente Beschäftigung mit dem Optimum
des Selbst, was
hier zu beachten ist und
für unser Thema relevant ist  ist, dass es
einen Weg gibt, auf dem das Optimum
in diesen Tests als männlich dargestellt zu werden scheint, und ich sage
das aus verschiedenen Gründen, einer davon ist, dass -
manchmal damit verbunden ist, Göttern zu dienen,
und die Götter sind Männer, sie sind männliche Götter, die
gegessen werden, also gibt es andere Götter  Ära
Göttinnen und Götter und wenn ich das tue -
verglichen mit einer Göttlichkeit wurde ich mit
einem männlichen Gott verglichen, gibt es auch die Idee, dass die
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Mama irgendwie an der
Entstehung des Universums beteiligt war, so
dass wir die Art von Passagen erhalten,
die die Art von Kosmogonie ausdrücken
in dem Dinge aus sich selbst erschafft, also hat
man hier das Selbst als eine Art
kausale Quelle von allem und eine Idee
ist, dass das erste, was
Ockman macht, eine weibliche Gefährtin ist, mit der
er kalkulieren kann, um so die
Welt hier zu erzeugen  Die Idee wäre
sehr, dass die einzige Quelle und Art
des Bewusstseins für alles männlich ist,
nicht weiblich. Dies ist vielleicht eine Idee,
dass wir auch ein antikes Recht hatten
, das es wert ist, dass die Standardperson ein
Mann und eine Frau sind  S  Irgendwie
nur in Bezug auf Männer oder als defekte
Männer verstanden oder ist vielleicht die Assistentin des
Mannes
so wieder der
Gedanke, dass die Frau da ist,
um dem Opfernden bei dem Ritual zu helfen,
so eine Vorstellung und im Lichte dessen ein
Gelehrter der Upanishaden  mit dem Namen Brian
Black Folgendes geschrieben hat, ist
morgen kein universelles Selbst in dem Sinne,
dass jeder eine Ottomane hat, sondern
eine bestimmte
Konstruktion des Selbst, die sowohl explizit jetzt ist
als auch durch bestimmte Arten von
Praktiken erlangt wird, die in erster Linie die Domäne
von Männern sind  okay, das klingt bisher nicht
sehr vielversprechend
für unser Projekt, aber wir haben uns
diese Passagen, in denen wir Philosophinnen haben, noch nicht angesehen,
und sie sind wirklich
Philosophen, da wir gleich sehen werden, also
zuerst noch einmal etwas über die Art von
Der dramatische Kontext, in dem sie
die beiden Dialogszenen einführten
, über die gesprochen werden sollte,
zeigte diesen von mir erwähnten Philosophen,
dessen Name ein weiteres Kind ist  und er
ist Grothman, er ist ein weiser Denker, und er
scheint in gewisser Weise eine Art
revolutionärer oder bahnbrechender Denker
innerhalb der vedischen Tradition zu sein. Er erscheint in
einem der frühesten und bestraften
Kodizes, der als der große bestrafte Wald bezeichnet
wird. Ich war einer der ältesten  Texte
aus den Upanishaden und daher die
ältesten existierenden philosophischen Werke,
und er ist jemand, der
diese Idee von Achmim und dem Selbst wirklich erforschen wird,
und wir werden das tatsächlich in
den Dialogen sehen, die er mit seinen Frauen führt,
also gibt es zwei  Szenen, in denen er
in der zweiten gezeigt wird, wie er mit Frauen spricht, werden
wir uns ansehen, es wird tatsächlich
mit einer seiner beiden Frauen sprechen, aber
in der ersten ist er der Kern eines
Königs und das ist ein ziemlich häufiger Kontext
dafür  philosophische Streitigkeiten bei den
Bestrafungen, also stehen all diese
Philosophen herum und es gibt
eine Art Wettbewerb zwischen ihnen, um zu
sehen, wer der Klügste ist oder wer die besten Antworten bekommen kann.
Die Antwort ist, dass Nobo  dy
sonst widerlegen kann, ist etwas,
das sich tatsächlich im restlichen
Indien durchsetzen wird. Die
altindische Philosophie
legt viel Wert auf dialektische Disputation,
und Sie haben uns bestraft, Sie kommen sogar auf die
Idee, dass wie der König sagen wird, dass
er eine große Anzahl von anbieten wird  Kühe an
denjenigen, der die überzeugendsten
philosophischen Argumente in Debatten vorbringen kann, also
konnte man damals tatsächlich gutes
Geld mit der Philosophie verdienen, wie sich die Zeiten
geändert haben,
also kommen wir zu diesem Test und insbesondere
und einer dieser Szenen ist ein
Urteil mit all diesen anderen Philosophen
und dann mit ihm  mit jemandem seines Namens in einen Streit gerät,
ist ein Typ über Chuck
the Navi und zeigt, dass sie die Frau ist, an der wir
interessiert sind, also nenne ich sie einfach
gaggy, weil es einfacher zu sagen ist und sie
eigentlich gehen muss und so ähnlich
den Ozean nicht widerlegen, was ich zumindest
irgendwie seine Weisheit teste, und in beiden Fällen
drängt sie ihn, zu
erklären, was das grundlegendste
Prinzip aller Dinge ist  Auch dies
könnte uns von der antiken
griechischen Philosophie her bekannt sein, wenn wir also an
die vorsokratischen Philosophen
denken, die dachten, dass alles auf
eines der Elemente wie Wasser reduzierbar ist, wie
Davids von meinem letzten sagte oder ihr Cleitus
sagte, dass alles auf reduzierbar ist
Feuer
Anaximander sagte, dass alles
von etwas kommt, das das Unendliche
oder Unbestimmte genannt wird, und sie
scheint als Java-Code zu fragen,
um ein solches Prinzip zu produzieren, also
fragt sie, was alles ist, basierend auf der Art und Weise, wie
sie sagt, was alles ist
eingewebt, also werde ich dir nicht das Ganze geben
, da es ziemlich lang ist, als ich
dir jetzt vorlesen werde. Einige Auszüge aus der
ersten Szene sind irgendwie zuerst
mit Randwissen beschäftigt, also sagt sie, es
gibt keine Ahnung, es mir seitdem zu sagen
Die ganze Welt ist hin und her gewebt, langes
Wasser auf was dann Wasser hin
und her gewebt ist, also sieht es fast so aus, als hätte sie
Phase richtig gelesen, also sagt er, ich kann
mir vorstellen, dass
alles ruht
als wha  Es ist Wasser, das darauf ruht oder darauf gewebt ist
, und er sagt auf Luft, und dann
sagt sie, gut, ich kann diese
Frage immer wieder stellen, auf dem, was seine Luft hin und her gewebt hat,
sagt er am Himmel, und sie
gehen ungefähr eine Seite lang weiter, er gibt ihr
immer mehr  und grundlegendere Prinzipien und
dann sagt sie an einem Punkt, dass
etwas in die Welt von Bronfman eingewebt ist
, was diese Art von göttlicher
Agentur oder sie selbst ist, und sie sagt, was
ist die Welt von Rahman, die hin und her gewebt ist
, und er sagte, nicht '  stell nicht zu viele
fragen gargy sonst zerbricht dir der kopf
du stellst zu viele
fragen über eine gottheit über die man
nicht zu viele fragen sollte
also stell nicht zu viele fragen
daraufhin verstummte Ghani okay also was
sollen wir nehmen  Aus dieser
Szene sieht es philosophisch so aus, als ob die
Idee sein könnte, dass, wenn Sie diese
Art von Regressionsargument aufstellen, also wenn Sie
gut sagen, welches Prinzip er als das
grundlegende Prinzip aller Dinge bezeichnet, ich Sie
nur bitten werde, ein
grundlegenderes zu nennen  Prinzip
also, wenn faiis kommt und sagt, alles ist
aus Wasser, alles ruht auf
Wasser, was vielleicht das ist, was Sie gesagt haben,
dann wird Gott sagen, okay, aber worauf ruht Wasser
, und wenn er dann sagt, ist
es Luft, was übrigens
interessant ist  Ein anderer
vorsokratischer Philosoph direkt
danach ist und Antisemitismus-Fakten, dass
alles aus Luft gemacht wurde, also ist es
fast so, als hätte sie hier die Geschichte
der Vorsokratiker gelesen und sie bewegt sich
durch sie, also Wasser auf Haar oder
auf Luft gewebt, nun, was Erica ist
Nun, es gibt noch etwas anderes, was
er sagt, den Himmel und so weiter und so fort,
dann kommt es zu dem, was er
als ursprüngliches oder fundamentales Prinzip zu betrachten scheint,
und das ist Brahma, von dem
wir erwarten würden, dass dies zumindest die Standardansicht ist
etwas Text, wenn du
uns bestrafst, wenn nicht die Akash im
Allgemeinen, und sie macht einfach die gleiche
Bewegung, damit er zu einem angeblich
grundlegenden Prinzip gelangt ist, und er/sie sagt,
okay, was ist das Prinzip hinter
deinem Fu  ndamentales Prinzip und er sagt
, frag nicht nach, er sagt nicht, dass es
keine Antwort gibt, er sagt etwas mehr in
der Art, dass es anmaßend ist
, die Frage überhaupt zu stellen, richtig, das ist
eine Art Tiefe, über die wir nicht hinausgehen sollten
, und es ist  nicht genau klar,
warum er ihr mit den seltsamen
Drohungen droht, dass ihr Kopf explodieren oder
zerbrechen könnte, was eine Idee ist, die man
tatsächlich in anderen Passagen der Upanishaden bekommt,
dass, wenn jemand im Streit besiegt wird,
sein Kopf zerbricht, also ist es ein sehr
anschauliches Bild dessen, was es ist  bedeutet,
in der Debatte besiegt zu
werden oder hier vielleicht überfordert zu sein. Eine
interessante Sache ist jedoch, dass Guardi
hier nicht als eine Art Verliererin behandelt zu werden scheint,
weil sie eine Frau ist,
tatsächlich gibt es nicht einmal einen Hinweis
auf ihr Wesen  ausdrücklich eine Frau Ich meine,
wir können sagen, dass sie eine Frau ist, aber der
Punkt ist, dass er nicht sagt, hör auf,
mich zu fragen, du bist nur eine Frau, er sagt, hör auf
, mich zu fragen, weil deine Frage
unangemessen geworden ist, weil  Weil man sich nicht
ewig zurückbilden kann, gibt es keinen
unendlichen Prozess, und wir sollten auch nicht
denken, dass sie sich irgendwie eingeschüchtert hat,
weil sie es
ein paar Seiten später noch einmal versucht und wir eine
noch interessantere Passage bekommen, die
wir jetzt sehen  Erhebt euch, um euch herauszufordern,
sagt Gargy mit
zwei Fragen, ähnlich wie ein wilder Krieger
aus Kashi oder Ladakh, der seinen
unbespannten Bogen spannt und zwei tödliche
Pfeile in die Hand nimmt, sich erheben würde,
um einen Rivalen herauszufordern, gib mir die Antworten auf
sie die Dinge  über dem Himmel die Dinge
unter der Erde und die Dinge zwischen
der Erde und dem Himmel sowie all
diese Dinge, die die Menschen hier als
Vergangenheit, Gegenwart und Zukunft bezeichnen, was
Java Gaea bedeutet, all dies ist hin und
her gewebt, und er sagt es über den Weltraum so  sie macht
die offensichtliche bewegung
sie sagt auf was dann sein raum
hin und her laufen wird er antwortete das gargy ist
brockman der hase übersetzer macht das
unvergänglich es ist weder natürlich noch
fein das ist weder noch  kurz noch lang es
hat weder Blut noch Fett ist ohne
Schatten oder Dunkelheit ist gut ohne Luft
oder Raum ohne Kontakt hat weder Geschmack noch
Geruch ohne Sehen oder Hören es ist
ohne Sprache oder Verstand es geht um
Energie Atem oder Mund es ist
unermesslich es  hat nichts Gutes in sich oder
außerhalb davon es heizt nichts
und niemand heizt es auf das ist brahman
das sieht aber nicht gesehen werden kann das hört
was nicht gehört werden kann
das denkt aber nicht gedacht werden kann
was aber wahrnimmt  kann nicht wahrgenommen werden,
außerdem ist dies unvergänglich, es gibt
niemanden, der sieht, niemanden, der hört, niemanden
, der denkt, und niemanden, der es wahrnimmt
Zu den anderen Weisen gewandt, die
anwesend sind, sollten Sie sich
glücklich schätzen, wenn Sie diesem Mann entkommen,
indem Sie ihm nur Respekt zollen, keiner von Ihnen
wird ihn jemals in einer theologischen Debatte besiegen,
okay, also gibt es eine Menge  Wir wollen
darüber sprechen, aber konzentrieren wir uns auf ein paar Hauptpunkte.
Beachten Sie zunächst, dass GOG, die weit
von hier entfernt behandelt wird, auf eine
Art abschätzige Art und Weise
behandelt wird  sie als eine Art
Nebenfigur oder als rangniedriger
als alle anderen dort, es ist fast so, als
ob sie diejenige ist, die Java-Code auf
seine größte Probe stellt und ihm dann
die Rolle des besten Philosophen zuspricht,
weil er schließlich auch eine
zufriedenstellende Antwort bemerkt  dass er
ihr eine andere Antwort gibt
als beim ersten Mal, fast so, als wäre sie
unzufrieden geblieben und vielleicht hat sie
Recht, unzufrieden zu bleiben, weil
er vorher gesagt hat, stell einfach nicht
so schwierige Fragen, du bist
unverschämt und jetzt er  gibt ihr ein gutes
Ende,
an dem Punkt, an dem
sie verstummt, erklärt sie einen weiteren Gewinner,
also ist das sehr interessant, denke ich, und
zeigt sicherlich, dass der Autor
dieses Wortspiels ist  Ich dachte, es wäre zumindest
fiktiv plausibel, dass eine Frau
in einer Debatte wie dieser eine wichtige Rolle spielt
, also sagt uns das über
Frauen, dass es nur ein Wort über die
philosophische Lösung ist, die er
produziert, was er sagt, wenn wir  Bewegen Sie sich
zu der Art des Heißen, dem Selbst oder
Harrys Kunden, aber oft ist es vielleicht
nicht so klar, dass Männer mit heißer Brühe
dasselbe sind, aber lassen wir das beiseite,
wir haben diesen Agenten oder
Bewusstseinssubjekt, dem alle
Eigenschaften fehlen  andere Dinge haben Recht,
so dass Sie es nicht riechen oder hören können oder
so, und es ist das, was daran beteiligt ist
, Wahrnehmungen richtig zu haben, also wird es nicht
wahrgenommen, aber es ist das, was wahrnimmt,
also ist die Idee hier, dass, wenn wir ein
grundlegendes Prinzip wollen, was  wir sollten uns
auf das Prinzip berufen, das
sich allem anderen bewusst ist, alles andere wahrnimmt,
alles andere
ganz klar erkennt, wie man es am
besten ausdrückt, aber dieses Thema des
Bewusstseins wird th sein  Die
grundlegendste Sache, die Guardi für
beeindruckend hält, ist eine gute Antwort.
Vielleicht ist sie deshalb so beeindruckend
, weil, sobald Sie das Thema Bewusstsein ansprechen,
klar ist, dass alles
andere irgendwie davon abhängig sein wird,
weil es das Ding ist, das
alles andere empfängt und  Es muss nicht umgekehrt
empfangen werden, also stoppen Sie
den Regress. Mein Punkt hier ist also, dass zum
Beispiel Essen geschmeckt werden kann und es
also etwas Grundlegenderes gibt
und hauptsächlich das Ding, das das
Schmecken durchführt, aber das Ding,
das den Geschmack erfährt  hat nichts
Grundlegenderes als es, weil es
nichts anderes gibt, was erlebt wird, es ist die
Art und Weise, wie es das Essen erlebt, also
hörst du auf
, um voranzukommen  eine weibliche Figur Es
gibt eine andere Szene in den Upanishaden,
in der es nicht so ist, als hättest du Gespräche mit
einer Frau, und es drückt etwas von dem
gleichen Phi aus  Losophische Ideen, also werde ich
es schneller durchgehen, aber es
lohnt sich, darüber zu sprechen, also hier ist, wie die
Show im Gespräch
mit seiner eigenen Frau gezeigt wird, deren Name Milben ist.
Sehr interessanterweise wird uns gesagt, dass er
es mehr mag  dieser Frau und seiner anderen
Frau und der Grund dafür ist, dass seine andere
Frau nur an dem interessiert ist,
was im Text
Frauenwissen genannt wird, während Maitreya irgendwie
philosophisch begabt oder geneigt ist und sie
daher besonders yogisch mag,
also kein Gefühl für die zweite  Frau,
aber wirklich interessant, dass
dies so positiv dargestellt wird, also
gibt es nichts, was man
mit ihr ins Gespräch bringen könnte, weil sie
ihn gefragt hat, wie
man Unsterblichkeit erlangt
erhalten Sie durch
verschiedene rituelle Mittel, zum Beispiel indem Sie
einen Sohn haben, und so wäre es eine
Standardsache, dass das Opfer sie
versucht, den Opfernden von
c zu erreichen  Wir sind ein richtiger Mann, also war der Ehemann so,
wie er nur da war, um ihm bei dem Ritual zu helfen,
also ist es wirklich interessant,
dass es sagen könnte, dass hier diejenige ist, die
fragt, wie man unsterblich wird, und
jetzt auch sehen, dass sie das wirklich
ist  das einzige, woran sie interessiert ist,
also hier ist die Szene, die sie sagt, wenn
ich die ganze Welt
voller Reichtum besitzen würde, würde mich das unsterblich machen,
und er sagt, nein, es würde dir nur erlauben
, das Leben einer wohlhabenden Person zu leben,
sagt sie, was das ist  Der Punkt,
etwas zu bekommen, wird mich nicht unsterblich machen Sagen Sie
mir stattdessen alles, was Sie wissen, dass sie ein nehmen sollen Sagen Sie, Sie waren
Ihnen immer sehr
lieb und jetzt sprechen Sie etwas sehr
Liebes
zu mir  Das
Interessante an dieser Passage ist also, dass
sie sich nicht nur erstens
als eine Art Philosophin
aussuchen darf, deren philosophischer Instinkt bewundernswert
ist, und zweitens, dass ihr Ziel
eine Art typischer E-Mail ist  eins und beachte,
dass er tatsächlich sagt, oh, ich mag dich so sehr
, ich mache mir sogar noch mehr Spaß als
vorher, weil du diese Frage
so wieder stellst, weit davon entfernt, sie irgendwie abzutun,
oh, du bist nur eine Frau  er antwortet
sehr positiv, lobt sie dafür, dass
sie die Frage überhaupt gestellt hat.
Hier ist seine Antwort auf die Frage, wann
ein Ehemann lieb ist, nicht aus Liebe
zum Ehemann, sondern aus Liebe
zu sich selbst. Hier ist das Wort Atzmon
dieser  man liebt einen ehemann man
liebt eine ehefrau nicht aus liebe zur ehefrau,
sondern aus liebe zu sich selbst
hält man eine ehefrau lieb man sieht man
mag wie sich selbst was man sehen
und hören sollte und über das man
nachdenken sollte und  Konzentrieren Sie sich, denn indem Sie sich selbst sehen
und hören und indem Sie sich selbst reflektieren
und sich auf sich selbst konzentrieren, erlangt man
das Wissen über die ganze Welt. Das ist
also eine sehr klare Aussage über die
Art von Theorie, die wir immer wieder sehen, und
sie werden von den Göttern bestraft, diese Idee ist
die grundlegende Sache  das Selbst ist,
und wenn Sie sich mit dem Selbst identifizieren möchten,
sollten Sie diese
anderen materialistischen Ziele nicht wertschätzen. Die Ziele, die Sie,
wie gesagt, oft
durch Rituale in einer Kette enthalten könnten, sollten
einfach versuchen, sich selbst als
nichts anderes als diese Art von Zielen zu sehen  des Zentrums des
Bewusstseins Sie könnten bezweifeln, nur auf
der Grundlage dessen, was ich gelesen habe, dass
er darüber nachdenkt. Sie könnten denken,
vielleicht bedeutet es für mein Haar nur,
dass Sie die Person mögen, die nicht
etwas Farbköderigeres oder irgendwie Gruseligeres ist wie
er  in der Passage mit gawky darüber zu
sprechen, aber lesen wir weiter, ich sehe, was er
sagt, und die folgenden Passagen, die er sagt,
wenn ein Stück Salz ins Wasser geworfen wurde, sich
in diesem Wasser aufgelöst hat und
es auf keine andere Weise als
von wo auch immer aufgenommen werden kann  wenn sie das Salz schlürfen,
ist dieses immense Wesen auf die gleiche Weise da,
dass es keine Grenze oder Grenze hat
und als eine einzige
Wahrnehmungsmasse aus und zusammen mit diesen
Wesen aufsteigt und
für sie verschwindet, so ich  sagen, nach dem Tod gab es
kein Bewusstsein, könnte zeigen, dass Sie jetzt antworten,
Sie haben mich völlig verwirrt, indem Sie sagten,
nach dem Tod gibt es kein Bewusstsein, und er
sagt, ich habe nichts gesagt, was
diesen Körper verwirrt, Sie sehen, dass er die Fähigkeit hat,
wahrzunehmen, wenn es ein gibt  Dualität
irgendeiner Art dann kann man riechen sehen hier
grüßen an den anderen denken oder dem anderen vorausgehen wenn
aber das Ganze zu einem
mannigfaltigen Selbst geworden ist dann wer ist da
wofür und wodurch wahrzunehmen aber wodurch
kann man ihn durch
wen wahrnehmen  Dieser ganzen Welt geht ein Blick voraus,
mit welchen Mitteln man den Wahrnehmenden
wahrnehmen kann, und Sie können dort sehen, was
er gesagt hat. Der Punkt, auf den er hinausläuft, ist
genau das, was er gesagt hat - Guardi, er
sagt, dass wir im Grunde den
Wahrnehmenden des Selbst haben, der das
Subjekt Ihres Bewusstseins ist  kann
nicht weiter zurückdrängen, weil du
den Wahrnehmenden nicht wahrnehmen kannst. Der Wahrnehmende
nimmt alles andere wahr, also stoppt es
das Buch, als wäre es okay,
jetzt große Frage, warum, warum haben wir zwei
Frauen  en präsentiert im großen Wald der
Bestrafung des Gesprächs mit diesem mächtigen
weisen Philosophen a jovica genau in den
Passagen, in denen er seine tiefste
philosophische Einsicht offenbart und diesen
Schritt macht, das Selbst als das
grundlegende Prinzip für alle Dinge zu postulieren, die
wir offensichtlich nicht kennen  Also müssen
wir raten, wie ich schon sagte. Ich denke nicht, dass es
sicher wäre anzunehmen, dass
dies eine Art Darstellung der
historischen Realität ist. Ich denke, dass es
einen Grund geben muss, warum der
Autor dies für mein Geld getan hat
Grund ist so etwas Yamaneika
ist ein sehr visionärer radikaler Denker in
der vedischen Tradition Ich habe das bereits gesagt,
aber vielleicht kann es jetzt ein wenig klarer werden,
warum, wenn die vedische Tradition eine ist, in
der Haushälter
Rituale durchgeführt haben, wissen Sie,
dass Sie Dinge wie Reichtum erlangen  Söhne, längeres
Leben, Gesundheit, mehr Kühe, so etwas,
dann ist es ziemlich radikal, wenn ein Genomica daherkommt
und sagt, eigentlich ist alles egal,
was Sie wirklich
tun sollten, ist das  Sich selbst als
Empfänger aller anderen Dinge einzufärben, denn
dann bist du das Prinzip von
allem und du bist vielleicht in gewissem
Sinne göttlich, das ist eine ziemlich radikale
Umkehrung der Werte der vedischen
Kultur, und vielleicht ist die Idee, dass
Frauen  Denker werden hinzugezogen, um zu zeigen,
wie radikal es richtig ist. So wie seine
Ideen radikal sind, ist er
zumindest darin ungewöhnlich, sowohl weibliche als
auch männliche Gesprächspartner zu nehmen. Vielleicht ist die
Idee auch, dass es nicht so wichtig ist,
ob ihre Frauen Männer sind  denn
jeder, der ein Selbst als Wahrnehmenden hat,
und das ist eine Idee, zu der wir gleich kommen werden,
wenn wir uns einen anderen Text aus
dem Mahabharata ansehen, aber zuerst möchte
ich nur ein Zitat von einem anderen Gelehrten
namens Steven Mcfist vorlesen, der etwas gesagt hat
Ähnlich wie das, was ich gerade über das
Erscheinen von Frauen in den Upanishaden
gesagt habe, sagt er, dass wir eine beträchtliche Anzahl von
Charakteren bestrafen, die Geschichten,
die auf früherem Textmaterial basieren,
normalerweise ausschließen würden  Von solchem
zusammengenommen scheint ihre Einbeziehung eher
in interner Dachboden und eine Entwi
klung der drafyn-Weltanschauung und wenig
r eine Widerspiegelung einer historischen Reali
ät zu sein, wenn Frauen in dieser Upanishadie in di
sem Licht betrachtet das Probl
m ein größeres Problem einer Veränderung zu sein schei
en  Ideologie hinter dem Besitz von
Wissen und was dieses Wissen ist, und
ich stimme dem zu,
also denke ich, dass es hier wirklich um Revision
und Theorieänderung geht und dass die Verwendung
weiblicher Charaktere manchmal auch Charaktere der
unteren Klasse und so weiter
sind, um das zu markieren  Änderung okay, also
schauen wir uns noch einmal einen anderen Text an.
Wir werden immer noch in der breiten medizinischen
Tradition sein. Es ist ein sehr berühmtes Werk, das
Mahabharata
EPIK, eine weitläufige Geschichte von Kriegsverrat,
Verrat, wie Sie es nennen, es
enthält eines der berühmtesten
philosophischen Werke der Geschichte  der
Menschheit, nämlich die Bhagavad-Gita, aber
ich werde nicht darüber sprechen,
ich werde über eine andere Passage sprechen,
in der zwei Charaktere es nicht sind
Wenn wir über dieses
Standby-Thema der indischen Philosophie sprechen,
nämlich Befreiung, und die Frage
, die zwischen diesen beiden
Charakteren gestellt wurde, ist, ob jemand, der
das Leben eines Haushälters führt, Befreiung erlangen kann
oder ob man
einer dieser wandernden Asketen werden muss, wie der
Buddhismus, den Jaynes tat  nicht dass alle
wandernden Asketen Buddhisten und
Jainas sind, also scheinen sie hier
wie ein Fleck in einer allgemein
empfehlenswerten Weltanschauung zu denken, aber aus
der Gesellschaft auszusteigen und wandernde
Asketen zu werden, und einer von ihnen erzählt dem anderen
die Geschichte eines Königs, der behauptete, etwas zu
erreichen  Befreiung, obwohl er immer noch als König agiert,
so hat er offensichtlich das ultimative Haushaltsrecht,
also hat er immer noch riesigen Reichtum, er hat
Abhängigkeit als Familie, er hat Armeen,
tatsächlich hat er Berater und trotzdem
sagt er, oh, ich bin befreit, ich bin frei von allen
Eigensinnen  zu körperlichen dingen und die
frage ist, ob das wirklich
glaubwürdig ist, was in der geschichte passiert ist,
dass dieser könig jonathon i. heißt
Ich habe gehört, dass diese Behauptung von einer wandernden Asketin aufgestellt wurde, die Salah heißt und überraschenderweise eine Frau ist. Denken Sie also daran, was ich zuvor gesagt habe. Es gibt all
diese Nervosität darüber, ob Frauen
sich auf dieses Leben der Entsagung
einlassen können  der Familie und einfach eine
Art Mönch sein und genau so
jemand, der das getan hat, also ist sie nicht
nur eine Coveransagerin und eine Asketin,
sondern sie ist eine Philosophin, die gut genug ist,
dass sie
durch ihr Yoga magische Kräfte erlangt hat, als sie davon hört
Dieser König John,
sie verwandelt sich in eine schöne
junge Frau und teleportiert sich an seinen Hof,
und sobald er dort ist, war
sie ich, wenn sie dort ist, hat sie sich nicht
nur dorthin teleportiert, sondern sie dringt jetzt
mit ihren Yoga-Kräften in seinen Geist ein und sie haben
wieder einen Dialog, aber das  Der Dialog
besteht eigentlich mehr oder weniger darin, dass er eine
Rede hält und dann sie eine Rede hält,
und das alles passiert in seinem Kopf, sodass
die anderen Leute dort wohl nicht
hören können, was sie sagt  telepathische
Kommunikation und er ist darüber nicht glücklich,
wie Sie sehen werden, also schauen wir uns zuerst
etwas genauer an, was Jonica
für sich selbst beansprucht, also hier ist eine Passage,
in der er erklärt, wie befreit er ist,
er sagt, ich habe keine Bindung an irgendetwas
Ob  es sei etwas, das mich zwingt oder
etwas, das zu mir gehört.
Ich empfinde keine Leidenschaft für diese Dinge,
denn Leidenschaften und Probleme
lenken gleichermaßen von dem Ziel ab, das ich früher verfolgt habe
, und ich bin froh, dass
sie mir alle gleich sind, und dann  später
in seiner Rede beschwert er sich darüber
, dass Sulla auf diese Weise in seinen Geist eingedrungen ist
, und er bringt vier Einwände vor, also ist der
erste erste Einwand, dass sie die
falsche Klasse ist, also ist sie eine dieser
priesterlichen Besetzungsmitglieder von Bachmann, er
gehört dem Militärorden an  er ist ein
Schuss über er ist ein Haushaltsvorstand, der er ein
berühmter Herr ist, sie sind aus verschiedenen
Clans, und am bezeichnendsten ist, dass hier ein
Kontakt zwischen einem Mann
und einer Frau ohne so große Ehe besteht  o
Er vergleicht im Grunde ihre Invasion
seines Geistes mit Yoga mit
Geschlechtsverkehr und sagt, dass dies
unangemessen ist, weil wir nicht verheiratet sind,
also hält er die Rede, in der er im
Grunde sagt, dass ich befreit bin und
du unangemessen bist, und dann hält sie eine
Rede zu welcher  Sie sagt, Ihre Rede war
schrecklich, ich werde eine viel bessere
Rede halten, die überzeugender ist, und sie
sagt einige interessante Dinge darüber,
was eine Rede überzeugend macht, und dann
sagt sie effektiv, wenn Sie so
befreit wären, wäre es Ihnen egal, dass ich
Wärst du eine Frau, würde es dir egal sein, dass ich
Schatzi und so weiter bin, weil du nicht
wissen würdest, dass all diese Eigenschaften von
Menschen irgendwie nach außen gerichtet sind, die Art
, wie sie äußere Bindungen mögen, und ihr
wahres Selbst ist das, was darunter liegt, also
hier ist, was sie ist  sagt, wenn du fest
entschlossen bist, in dir selbst
und in einem anderen gleich zu sein, warum fragst du mich, wer
du bist und wer du bist,
warum tut König von Mithila jemandem, der
von den Gegensatzpaaren befreit ist, Erfolg?  h
da dies mir gehört und dies nicht mir gehört
frage wer bist du wessen bist du und
woher kommst du wenn du völlig
frei bist was habe ich falsch gemacht
und dir mit meinem Wesen Einzug gehalten Asketen
müssen in einem leeren Haus wohnen  Welchen
Verstoß habe ich wem zugefügt, als
ich in dieses leere Haus kam, mit
anderen Worten, wenn er wirklich unser Ansager ist, ist
er wirklich befreit, dann sollte er
frei von Anhaftungen an Dinge sein und er
sollte in seinem Geist wie ein leeres
Haus sein  sollte niemand zu Hause sein, wenn
sie hineingeht, sollte niemand
da sein, um sie zu verwirren oder sich in
ihr Gespräch einzumischen - das ist also ziemlich interessant
und es ist besonders interessant für uns,
dass sie Einwände gegen seine Einwände gegen die
Tatsache hat, dass sie eine Frau ist,
also Bryan  Schwarz hat wieder
etwas Interessantes darüber gesagt. Er sagt,
Suliban vertrete ein Modell für
Erleuchtung
, das jenseits der Dualität der Geschlechterunterscheidung
liegt und daher
für Frauen ebenso verfügbar ist wie für Männer, und
ich denke, t  Das ist genau richtig, und es gibt
einen Grund dafür, der darin besteht,
dass sie auch dieser Theorie von Mahatma so zugeschrieben hat,
dass das Selbst diese Art von Wunder liegt,
wenn Sie sich vorstellen, dass
dieses Selbst als physische Person für
alle gleich ist, denken Sie einfach, es ist das
Das Zentrum des Bewusstseins ist der Wahrnehmende
von allem und das hat
nichts mit Ihrem Geschlecht zu tun.
Vielleicht denken Sie hier wieder an etwas
in der antiken griechischen Philosophie, das wir
richtig gesehen haben, die Idee von
Encarnación, sodass das wahre Selbst eine
immaterielle Seele sein könnte  Das kann zuerst ein Mann
sein, dann eine Frau, dann ein nichtmenschliches
Tier, und ähnlich ist hier das Selbst, das
reine Selbst, hinter einem Geschlecht, es ist nicht
geschlechtsspezifisch. Dies ist vielleicht ein Unterschied zu dem,
was wir
letzten Monat bei traditionelleren poetischen und vedischen Ideen gesehen haben  wurde
jetzt als männlich dargestellt, insbesondere
gibt es eine Art fortgeschrittenere Ansicht,
in der Hutchman überhaupt kein Geschlecht hat, und
Sie können sehen, wie dies herauskommt und
Avas Reaktion darauf beruhigt  Kings Kritik an
ihr. Als sie erklärt, warum es
für sie in Ordnung war, in seinen Geist einzudringen,
sagt sie Folgendes: Eigentlich ist das
da kein direktes Zitat, dies
ist eine Art Zusammenfassung von einem anderen
Gelehrten ihrer Punkte, aber hier ist  Was
sie im Grunde sagt, da derselbe
Osmane sowohl Frauen als auch Männer animiert,
sind Frauen in der Lage, den gleichen
Weg wie Männer zu gehen. Das ist das Erste, was sie als
Zweites sagt, dass eine wirklich weise Person
, die die Einheit des Ungeraden erkannt hat,
nicht versuchen wird, irgendjemanden zu verurteilen,
einschließlich  jede Frau nach Kaste oder Familienstand
, die dritte Sache ist, dass der
Osmane niemandes Eigentum ist, also
erkennt eine wirklich weise Person, dass - die
Haskell-Frau, zu der sie gehört,
bedeutungslos ist, viertens und schließlich, da der
Osmane eine intellektuelle oder spirituelle
Gemeinschaft zwischen allen ist  Zwei Personen,
darunter ein Mann und eine Frau, sind nicht
dasselbe wie physische Vereinigung und nicht falsch
, also ist Ruth Vinita die Gelehrte, die
diese Posi irgendwie zusammenfasst
Ich denke, dass
sie das genau richtig macht, also ist die Idee, dass,
wenn Sie sich mit Ihrem
Osmanen selbst identifizieren, was Sie
tun müssen, wenn Sie wirklich befreit sind, dann werden
Sie sehen, dass Klassenunterschiede und Geschlechtsunterschiede
Sie nicht interessieren  wird auch
sehen, dass der Verkehr der Gedanken
nicht dasselbe ist wie Geschlechtsverkehr, wie
er andeutet,
und so enthüllt seine ganze Kritik an
ihr unwissentlich, dass er überhaupt nicht
befreit ist, und erklärt
dann irgendwie, warum
er nicht befreit ist  oder woher er
weiß, dass er überhaupt nicht hätte befreit werden können,
tatsächlich ist das der
Grund, warum sie da ist, um seine Heuchelei zu enthüllen
und zu behaupten, sowohl ein
erfolgreicher Haushälter zu sein, in diesem Fall
tatsächlich ein König, als auch ein berühmter Herr oder ein
Befreiter  Person, die sie sagt, das kann nicht sein,
weil Sie nur an all die
Eigensinne und Verantwortlichkeiten denken, die Sie
als König haben, also wie ich sagte, Sie haben
alle seine Angehörigen, Sie haben eine Familie,
Sie haben großen Reichtum, yo  Du hast Armeen
und keines dieser Dinge sind Dinge, die
du wirklich haben könntest, wenn du wirklich
befreit wärst, also ist sie sehr gegen die Idee,
dass du dich nicht von
den Dingen in deiner Umgebung oder den
Dingen, die du schätzt, befreien kannst, indem du dir einfach sagst,
dass du es bist  Schätze sie nicht
mehr, wenn du die Anhaftung an die Dinge aufgeben willst, musst du
die Dinge tatsächlich
loswerden und du musst tun, was
sie getan hat, du musst
kein Haushaltsvorstand mehr werden, der nicht länger an
Dingen wie Fortpflanzung beteiligt ist, was ist  die
Standardaufgabe der Frau kein
Vermögen mehr zu haben sich nicht mehr in der
Politik zu engagieren man muss aussteigen man
muss ein wandernder Asket werden wie sie
okay das sind also zwei wirklich interessante
Textbeweise für die Art und Weise
, wie Frauen in der Antike gedacht wurden
von klinischer Kultur, das
wollte ich in diesem Vortrag machen, aber
ich möchte noch eine andere Sache ansprechen,
die
chronologisch etwas später liegt, insbesondere die  Texte oder der
Autor Ich werde mich auf seinen
Namen konzentrieren, den er nie gekocht hat, den er mehr als
ein Jahrtausend später liebt, aber er ist in gewisser
Weise der Höhepunkt oder der Höhepunkt einer
Tradition, an die viele Menschen
wahrscheinlich denken werden, wenn sie daran denken
über die Rolle der Frau in der alten
indischen Kultur und das ist Tantra okay,
also was ist Tantra nun, das ist eine
komplizierte Frage, und ich bräuchte eine
ganze Vorlesung, um wirklich zu erklären, was
Tantra ist. Es wird im
Podcast behandelt, wenn Sie sich meine
Versuche anhören möchten  Erklären Sie es, es ist sicherlich ein
Thema, von dem die Leute sehr
ungenaue Vorstellungen haben, also bringen die meisten Leute das
Wort Tantra in erster Linie an
das Thema Sex und deshalb denken die Leute
vielleicht, dass es eine Art
Beziehung zu Frauen hat, also ist das in
gewisser Weise falsch  es ist in gewisser Weise richtig, der Grund
, warum es in gewisser Weise richtig ist, ist, dass, wie wir gleich sehen werden,
Tantra definitiv
etwas über die Beziehungen
zwischen Mann und Frau zu sagen hat und sie tatsächlich
männlich macht.  Die weibliche Beziehung ist
wirklich grundlegend für das gesamte
Universum, das stimmt, was nicht so
toll ist, ist die Idee, dass es beim Tantra im
Grunde nur um Sex geht,
also gibt es Passagen, in denen Tantra-
Autoren sind, darunter dieser Typ Abbe Nava,
der übrigens tatsächlich in zwei Bädern lebte
gibt es Passagen  in denen
von sexuellen Ritualen gesprochen wird, die aber
in der Literatur nicht sehr häufig vorkommen und
dann eigentlich nur eine von vielen verschiedenen
Arten von Ritualen, die im Tantra wichtig sind,
eigentlich etwas, das
viel prominenter ist, ist die Verwendung von sogenannten
Mantras,
also Ritualen  Gesänge und wieder eines
der Hauptbeispiele wäre dieses
einsilbige Ohm, das
eigentlich ein Mantra ist, also sagst du es
immer und immer wieder richtig und es
soll eine Art Meditationstechnik sein,
vielleicht soll es dir helfen, Atemkontrolle zu erlangen
aber es gibt auch die Idee, dass
Sie, wenn Sie ein Mantra sagen,
den Prozess nachstellen, durch den das
gesamte Universum erschaffen wurde, also den
Atemzug  aus dir heraus soll wie
die schöpferische Kraft sein, die aus dem
Göttlichen hervorkommt und das Universum erschafft, und
vielleicht kommt der Atem zurück in dich,
damit das Universum letztendlich zu Gott zurückkehrt,
okay, es gibt viele
verschiedene Arten von Tantra, die sie
teilen  Diese konzentrieren sich auf Rituale, es gibt ein
buddhistisches Tantra,
es gibt auch Tantra aus
der Tradition der Atemmedizin,
worüber ich sprechen werde.
Einige Leute sprechen hier oft von
hinduistischem Tantra, obwohl ich
das Wort hinduistisch vermeide, weil es so ist
ziemlich problematisch ist kein altes
Wort, also etwas, das wir irgendwie
auf die alte indische Literatur projizieren
, deshalb habe ich es verwendet, aber die Leute
sprechen häufig über hinduistisches Tantra,
und dies schließt diesen Denker
Abhinavagupta, den
ich ein Hauptfach war, oder Autor über Tantra ein
Insbesondere er stammt aus einer Tradition
namens Shaivismus.
Shaivismus bedeutet Anbetung des Gottes Shiva,
und in seiner Version von Shaivismus haben Sie
die Idee, dass Shiv  Dieser höchste Gott spielt
gewissermaßen die Rolle, die
wir von Brockman in den Upanishaden oder ganz unten in
den Upanishaden gesehen haben, und auch die Rolle, die er
im Vedanta spielt, also eine Art einzige
Quelle des Bewusstseins, die
alle Dinge hervorbringt, und es gibt eine besondere Sache
über Tantra, das es wirklich
von sagen wir Vedanta unterscheidet, das wiederum eine
Art klösterliche philosophische Theorie ist,
wo alles aus einer einzigen
Quelle des Bewusstseins kommt
Erkennen Sie
Ihre Identität mit diesem Prinzip, also
sagte IV Nava etwas wirklich Nettes
über die Rolle der körperlichen Rituale beim
Erreichen dieser Vereinigung. Er sagte, der Körper
sollte als voll von allen Pfaden angesehen werden,
die aus allen Gottheiten bestehen und daher
zu einem Objekt gemacht werden müssen  der kontemplation
der anbetung und der riten der
erfüllung okay so weit klingt das sehr
philosophisch klingt auch sehr
patriarchalisch richtig also haben wir das  Der männliche
Gott Shiva, der die Quelle von
allem ist, und Sie sollten
Ihre Identität mit ihm erkennen, aber es
gibt noch mehr, weil es ein anderes
göttliches Prinzip
oder eine andere Gottheit namens
Shakti gibt,
also ist dies die weibliche Ergänzung von
Shiva, und sie sprechen manchmal
darüber  dass ohne beide Prinzipien
nichts passieren kann, also ist eines der Sprichwörter
im Tantra, dass Shiva ohne Shakti
eine Leiche ist, die im Sanskrit
eigentlich eine Pumpe ist, also braucht man sowohl Mann
als auch Frau, um etwas zu erledigen.
Natürlich ist die Grundidee hier das
Die Produktion des Kosmos ist so etwas
wie die Reproduktion durch sexuelle Vereinigung
und genau diese Idee ist der Grund, warum sexuelle
Praktiken oder eine Form von Ritualen
in Tantra integriert werden könnten, weil
es Ihnen helfen würde, Ihre Identität
mit diesem Paar von Prinzipien zu erkennen, die
Shakti erreicht und in denen sie zusammenarbeiten
alles wieder in
ordnung zu bringen jeder neuling hat etwas sehr schönes
daran sagt er der
der sich gleichzeitig manifestiert  Da der
Vater und die Mutter einmal Schöpfer des
gesamten Universums ist
, könnte man viel darüber sagen,
natürlich ist dies in gewisser Weise eine
Art mythische Vorstellung, die wir in
vielen anderen Kulturen von der ursprünglichen
Beziehung zwischen Mann und Frau finden können
zwischen aktiv und passiv sein oder
zwischen energisch und erholsam und so weiter, also
gibt es viele Arten von Dualitäten, mit denen
sie hier herumspielen, und es
wird in der tantrischen Literatur ausgesponnen,
es gibt eine nette Erklärung dafür, die
ich gerne lesen würde  Das
Folgende ist von einem Gelehrten, den ich
Jägern
und sowohl hinduistischen als auch buddhistischen Jägern gebe und
eine höchste Nicht-Dualität visualisiere
, die nur in Form einer diametralen Polarität ausgedrückt werden kann, zu der
sie
das eine Paradigma gewählt haben, das zweifellos
einzigartig passend ist  sowohl ein
psychologischer als auch ein mythischer Blickwinkel,
um diese Polarität zu veranschaulichen, nämlich Mann und
Frau, eher Mann und Frau und
ihre kosmische Version Gott und Göttin und
eine Folge davon  in der gemäßigten
Tradition ist, dass es ein ziemlich
beeindruckendes Maß an Offenheit gegenüber Frauen gibt.
Tatsächlich ist eine Sache bei Tantra im
Allgemeinen, dass Tantra nicht verlangt, dass die
Menschen auf das Leben des
Haushälters verzichten, also haben Sie Tantra
Kamal nicht so, wie Sie es haben  Buddhistische
und jainistische Mönche Tantra ist in der Tat eine Reihe
von Ritualen, an denen sich jeder beteiligen kann, sodass
Sie ein König, ein reicher Mann oder eine
reiche Frau sein und sich
beispielsweise auf Mantras oder andere Rituale einlassen können
, die in tantrischen Texten empfohlen und beschrieben werden
man muss nicht
alles aufgeben, um
die einheit mit diesem höchsten prinzip zu erreichen oder eine verwirklichung seiner einheit mit
diesem höchsten prinzip shakti shiva und
aus diesem grund zeigen tantrische texte
eine recht positive einstellung gegenüber
frauen frauen serie nur noch ein letztes zitat
aus a  Gelehrte des Tantrismus
Ein Hauptmerkmal des Tantra ist der
höhere Standard, zu dem sie die
Weiblichkeit erhoben haben. Shakti manifestiert sich bei
Frauen, wenn sie mit
Ehrfurcht und Reinheit angegangen werden  d Hingabe erheben sie
Männer zum Standard der Götter, also scheint es
eine ziemlich gute Note zu sein, um noch einmal zu beenden. Beachten Sie
, dass dies ein wenig
aus männlicher Sicht gesehen wird. Wenn
Frauen also mit dem Hinweis
angesprochen werden, haben sie die Männer zum Standard erhoben  von
Göttern, um eine Spur dieser alten Idee von ihnen zu erkennen, dass
das Opfer oder die Frau ihm hilft
, aber eigentlich denke ich, wenn Sie die
Shiva-Theorie wirklich ernst nehmen
, sehen Sie das, obwohl wir nicht die
Ideen wie in den Upanishaden haben  Das Geschlecht
fällt einfach weg, wenn
wir die höchste Ebene erreichen, wir haben die Vorstellung,
dass die Geschlechter auf der höchsten
Ebene gleich sind, also haben Sie immer noch Mann und Frau,
aber Mann und Frau kooperieren
und ohne das eine ist das andere bedeutungslos
und so manchmal Menschen  rede nicht nur
über das Rasieren, sondern was ist mit der gemeinsamen Verehrung
von Shiva und Shakti als eine
Art einzige Tradition, verschiedene Teile und
Stränge des Tantra könnten Shiva
oder Shakti mehr betonen, je nachdem, aber ich denke, das
b  Die grundlegende Idee hier ist, dass die einzige
Quelle aller Dinge ein einziges
Prinzip ist, das wir als eine Dualität begreifen, nämlich
das Männliche und das Weibliche.
Okay, also das war es für diesen Vortrag, wenn es
Ihnen gefallen hat, und ich hoffe, Sie werden das
nächste Mal dabei sein, wenn ich  Fahren Sie fort,
hier in dieser Serie über weibliche Denker in der
Antike und im Mittelalter über weibliche Intellektuelle in der islamischen Kultur zu sprechen. Vielen Dank
fürs Zuhören